let's get to our live calls today the
most important people for the show are
the viewers and the listeners without
you I'm a guy in a room talking to no
one and it's sad so uh we take calls via
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord and let's see what is on
people's minds let's start today with is
it Desmond or desmu from Birmingham
Desmond what's going on today hey I'm
chilling man good Hey so uh my question
for you was
um it seems to be that there is a trend
to undermine American democracy by the
right as well as things like encouraging
General political violence do you think
that this is a trend that will continue
into the future or do you think that
this is something that will slow down it
will continue unless there is something
that stops IT and says that it's
unacceptable and that is a number of
different words
I'm sorry do you think like worsen or
maybe like pretty much the same it is
now I I think it will almost certainly
worsen Barack Obama at a speech uh
earlier this week in Nevada
um made this point and I think he made
it astutely and accurately which is when
you have one side that generically will
condemn violence when there is violence
but they will coddle and Inspire and
allude to it being an acceptable form of
political speech and then their
followers start to do the violence in
small scale stuff like an individual
attack on Paul Pelosi and in large-scale
stuff like the January 6 Trump riots and
yes the Trump rioters are slowly being
held accountable as their cases are
adjudicated but those who inspired that
event have not been held accountable why
on Earth would they stop to the extent
that they believe it benefits them and
it's good to keep the other side scared
which clearly they believe something has
to happen to get them to stop
okay hey thanks for having my question
absolutely everything things are okay in
Alabama
uh it's I mean I'm in Birmingham so it's
kind of like a blue bubble surrounded in
a sea of red so it's a little different
here compared to the rest of the state
so I can't really speak for the more
rural areas but we're we're chilling in
Birmingham it's nothing too out of the
ordinary right now you can get like a
good uh you can get a good cappuccino in
Birmingham
yeah it's nothing too out of the
ordinary it's kind of like a it's not
like a huge City or anything comparable
to like Atlanta or anything but it's
pretty Normie there's like you know what
I mean there's like nothing too odd
going on I would love to visit someday
hey it'd be cool to see you man all
right Birmingham appreciate the call
very much thank you one of our sponsors
today is blue chew a unique online
service delivering the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's supply for free so if you
think you could benefit from an extra
boost of confidence when it's time all
you have to do is take a short quiz on
their website a licensed doctor approves
your prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discrete package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA the entire
process is just a few clicks go to
bluetooth.com the link is underneath
this video they'll give you an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code Pacman all you have to do is
pay five dollars shipping